[Music]
hey
[Music]
but it has changed now
everything has changed
[Music]
we used to make everything
like our tools plates and cups out of
natural materials
but now everything is plastic
[Music]
all of this dirtiness is coming from the
garbage
it doesn't go away
it's harmful for your body and to
everyone else
when animals drink the water it's
harmful for them as well
that's why it's important to stop it
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of the fish die and float to the
surface of the river
[Music]
i don't know where the water comes from
but it's so dirty we can't even wash our
hands
pieces of plastic and trash float in our
water
the ganges is supposed to be clean
but here it is dirty
[Music]
it feels terrible living like this
the trash smells awful there are lots of
mosquitoes circling our home
and our children get sick
[Music]
the plastic products at the market come
from the outside what can we do about it
if they are only selling products with
plastic
what can we do
when the market stops selling it
that's how we can stop using plastic
our idea is that we should collect all
the plastic trash and take it outside of
our village
making one spot to collect it
and then let the trash collectors come
and take it away to process it
but no one comes to collect it
it's all still here
even though the government is banning
plastic
it is hard to execute
there is a lot that needs to be improved
and fixed
there is cleaning work that has to be
done around the ganges which is
important
and we want to support it
we can live without plastic
[Music]
you